The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: The technical
topic for today,
we start-- I rushed,
right at the end,
a little bit about tangent
and normal unit vectors.
I'm going to just
recap that quickly.
And then we're going to go
on really a review, which
by a review, this is the sort of
stuff that, for the most part,
I'm sure you've seen in 801
Physics and other Physics
you've had before.
And that's impulse-- linear
momentum, and impulse.
So that'll be a quick review.
And then the third subject
is one that's much deeper,
and this is angular momentum.
And angular momentum
with respect
to moving points,
which you probably
haven't encountered before.
So those are the three
topics for the day.
Let's get started.
So last time, the
piece that I rushed
a bit is this notion of
tangent and normal coordinates.
So I gave this--
had this example.
You're driving down the road,
you're drunk or whatever.
And when you're at this point,
this point, and this point,
I'd like to know what
the accelerations are.
So I'll call this 1, 2, 3.
And this curve, y, is of the
form some y of some f of x.
And in this case,
it's A sine kx.
And k is what's
known as wave number.
This is 2 pi over the wave
length, 2 pi over lambda.
And the wave length then is,
for example, from here to here.
Now, the velocity-- I'm
going to pick a point here.
The velocity at
any point, we know,
is just the tangent to the path.
So this is the path,
and this is horizontal.
So you're driving-- driving
down the road like this.
That's what we're
trying to do here.
The gravity's down
into the board.
It doesn't really
come into the problem.
So the velocity, at any
point-- at anytime--
it's a vector-- we can
describe as a magnitude.
And in a unit vector,
we'll call ut which
is the tangent unit vector.
And at any instant in time, it's
just aligned with the tangent
to the curve.
And it's perpendicular partner
is a normal unit vector, which
it points inward on the curve.
And this will be un.
Now, we're interested
in accelerations,
so we'll need to take
a derivative of this.
So I was going to
say, taken aside.
But I won't.
So the acceleration
vector, we have
to take the derivative of this.
Well, it's a v dot
ut plus a v ut dot.
It's a unit vector.
And we've encountered
this problem
before because if this
rotates, the unit vector
has a non-zero derivative
because of this rotation.
And this derivative
of the unit vector
is given by theta dot u m
hat Now, what's theta dot?
Well, on this curve,
at any instant in time,
here's u-- can't
draw arrows today.
Here's your ut.
At any instant when you're
traveling along on a curve,
you are going around the circle
of some radius we'll call rho.
So there's some
radius of curvature
at any instant in time.
And that radius, as you drive
along in a little time delta t,
you go forward an
amount, rho theta dot,
is the velocity at which you're
traveling tangent to the curve.
There's an angle in here, so
in here, there's some delta.
You advance some delta theta, so
our omega is a velocity, right?
So rho theta dot its
velocity, and that gives you
this velocity
magnitude, v. And we've
gone through-- I'm
not going to go
through that little derivative--
that little argument before,
but the change in direction
of this unit vector,
ut, when you go forward a little
bit is actually inward, un,
by an amount rho theta dot-- by
an amount theta dot one times
theta dot.
So we've done- I'm
not going to do
that piece of the
derivative we did before.
But here is this derivative
of the unit vector.
It's theta dot un.
So if we substitute
those back in here,
we can get an expression
for our acceleration.
This is just the acceleration
along the path plus v theta dot
un.
And then we need to
take into account
the fact that we know that v,
the magnitude of velocity--
the speed in other
words-- is rho theta dot.
And that means theta
dot is v over rho.
So if we plug that
in up here, then
we get a final expression
for our acceleration,
v dot ut plus v
squared over rho un.
And that v squared
over rho-- this
is a centripetal
acceleration term.
You're going around a curve.
There is an acceleration inward.
It's just like as we did
from polar coordinates.
It comes from rotating things.
Well, as soon as you
go around the curve,
you're going to generate
an acceleration that
is of the same
kind, but now we--
because you tend
to know speed, it's
easier to express it this
way when you're doing
these tangent normal problems.
And this is just the
acceleration along a path,
the usual hit the gas
petal and speed up.
That's this term.
So the piece that
I didn't have time
to put up last time,
which is in the book as
is this little derivative--
the derivation of that
is one page in one of the
early chapters of the book.
How do you get rho?
And rho, when you have
y as a function of x,
there is just this formula from
mathematics-- from calculus--
that says rho is dy dx 1 plus dy
dx quantity squared to the 3/2
power all over the
magnitude of d2y dx squared.
And you just calculate these
quantities and plug them in.
So for y equals a sine kx,
then dy dx is Ak cosine kx
and d2y dx squared is
minus a k squared sine kx.
So we now have these
two quantities.
We pick a value
of x which we want
to know the answer, like 0.1.
So at 0.1, kx is pi over 2
because sine is a maximum.
X is lambda over 4.
kx is pi over 2.
Sine kx is 1.
Cosine kx is 0.
And so we can calculate rho.
1 plus and dy dx the
derivative, is cosine.
That's 0.
So this term in here is 0.
And this is to the 3/2.
That's pretty easy to calculate.
This term down here, d2y dx
squared, well, sine of kx is 1.
So that's minus Ak squared, but
this is an absolute value sign.
So this just turns out
to be 1 over Ak squared.
And you plug-in some numbers.
I'm going to let my
lambda be 150 meters.
My amplitude here that I'm
swerving back and forth,
let's make that 5 meters.
We need a-- that's all
we need to get rho.
So rho, in this case,
works out to be 114 meters.
So the radius of curvature,
this road that I'm driving down,
at that point right at the peak
in the curve is 114 meters.
So the acceleration
that I'm looking for,
a, well, it's v dot ut.
And if I'm not
accelerating-- I'm not
hitting the gas petal
at constant speed,
I'll let that would be 0.
And the other one,
then, is v squared
over rho of the un direction.
And let's let v equal-- whatever
I have here in my example--
20 meters per second,
which is about 40 knots.
And a knot is 15% more
than a mile per hour,
so it's somewhere about
45 miles an hour, so
a typical road speed.
Driving down the road,
20 meters per second,
now you can plug-in here.
You can plug-in
here, and you'll find
that the acceleration
that I worked out here
is 3.51 meters
per second squared
and in what direction is it?
What direction is
that acceleration?
AUDIENCE: The normal.
PROFESSOR: It's in
the normal direction.
Is it to the inside of the curve
or the outside of the curve?
AUDIENCE: Inside.
PROFESSOR: Inside.
It's always to the
inside of the curve.
So these tangent
normal coordinates
are really simple coordinates.
They're meant for a particular
kind of simple problem
when you know the path.
And it's just defined,
the normal un is positive,
always inward to the
center of the curve,
pointing toward the
center of rotation
where that radius of--
where your radius of curve
is, always pointing
at the origin
of that radius of your curve.
So g is order of 10
meters per second squared,
so that's about a third of a g.
Is 1/3 of a g enough to notice?
Yeah, absolutely!
You'll get-- when you push
to the side of the car,
you do that .
So let's move-- any
questions about that?
I'm going to move on next.
If not, I'm going to move on
to linear impulse and momentum.
And this will be a quick
review because this
consists of the kind of physics
that you've done lots of times.
We're going to hit it
quickly and then move on
to angular momentum.
So we know for a particle--
this is what Newton told us.
We've got a particle
here and some mass, m.
We know for a particle-- and it
has some external forces on it.
We know for a particle that the
sum of these external forces--
it's a vector sum--
is equal to the mass
times the acceleration for the
particle, Newton's Second Law.
And that's the mass times the
derivative of the velocity
with respect to time.
That's where we
get acceleration.
So this formula we can
just rearrange the dt's
a little bit.
So the summation of the
forces, dt, is m dv.
And I want to integrate these.
So if I integrate this
over time, from t1 to t2,
this equality says we're going
to find some change in velocity
from v1 to v2.
And this is our
impulse-- this is
the beginnings of our
impulse-momentum relationship.
We tend to call the integration
of forces over time, impulse.
And if you have a
nonzero impulse,
that leads to a change
in the linear momentum.
So when you carry
it out so writing
this a little bit different
way, you can do summation
because these are vectors, and
we have rules about vectors.
You can bring the summation
outside of the integral.
So that this says that the
summation of the integral
from t1 to t2 of
these external forces
is just mv2 minus mv1
because the integral
on the right-hand
side is really simple.
And we'll finally
state this in a way
that we most commonly use it,
moving this term to the left.
So you start off with an
initial momentum, mv1.
You add to it the summation
of the impulses that
occur over time, t1, t2
of the external forces,
and you get the
final momentum mv2.
And this is the way you
usually use the formula.
So what happens if there's
no external forces?
That's where we get the law
of conservation of momentum.
If there are no external
forces on the particle,
the momentum doesn't change and
mv1 has got to be equal to mv2.
So just a really trivial
example drawing for something
that we've done before.
You got the block
sliding down the hill.
Draw your free body diagram.
You got friction, got
gravity, got a normal force.
And we'll set ourselves up with
a coordinate system aligned
with the motion
we're interested in.
So this is an
inertial system, x,y.
And we've done this
problem before.
So we said the
summation-- we found out
that the summation of the forces
in the x direction-- and this
is a good moment to take
an aside for a second.
This was a vector expression.
But you can break it--
you can implement it--
you can break it down into its
individual vector components.
So that equation gives
you-- for particles--
gives you three sub-equations
one in the x, one in the y,
one in the z.
And you can use them
each independently.
So in this case, we're going to
use-- only need the x component
in order to do the problem.
So the sum of the forces
in the x direction,
in this problem which
we had done before,
is mg sine theta, that
component of gravity pulling it
down the hill, minus
mu mg cosine theta.
And that's the friction.
And none of these are
functions of time.
So that whole thing
is just some constant.
I'll just call it k.
So the total forces on the
system in the x direction
is just some constant.
And that makes this integral
up here pretty trivial
to implement.
So now we can say that mv1--
I'll make it v1x to emphasize
that integral from 0, t1 to t2..
But I'm going to let
t1 be 0 because it
makes the problems easier.
So from 0 to t of
k dt equals mv2--
I can't write this morning--
in the x direction.
And at v1, x is 0, starts
off at 0 time and 0 velocity
when you let it
go to start with.
Then, this term will go away.
And we just implement
this integral.
And the integral of k dt is?
kt, right?
So this says then that kt
evaluated from 0 to some time
that we want to know the answer
is mv2 in the x direction.
And so let's let
t equal 3 seconds.
You find out that
v 2x is 3k over m.
And in this problem, then
that looks like 3g sine theta
minus mu cosine theta.
So it's really an
almost trivial example.
It's not a hard example,
but it emphasizes
all of the key points
in the problem.
Start off with a
vector equation.
You can apply it in any one
of the three vector component
directions.
We integrate the
forces-- the sum
of the forces on the object
in that direction over time.
And you apply the
impulse-momentum formula,
and you get the answer.
You can do that.
So that basic
step-by-step process
is how basically most
impulse-momentum problems
are done.
And if there's no
forces, then you
have conservation of momentum.
So let's do-- this
was for particles.
Just a quick reminder
of we need to ask
ourselves does this apply to
groups of particles, systems
of particles.
Well, remember, that we
said if you've got a bunch
of particles, a system--
all of these are
the mi''s-- we've already
figured out that the total mass
of the system times the
velocity of the center of mass--
so g is my center of mass with
respect to my inertial frame.
So this is the momentum of
the system that was just
a summation of the individual
mivi's with respect
to-- And furthermore, we
took the derivative of this,
so this is the
momentum of the system.
The time derivative
of the momentum
should be the external forces
so that we were able to--
by taking that derivative,
you get mt, the total mass,
times vg with respect to o dot.
And that had better give you
v equal to the summations
of the external forces
on all the particles
because you can do it
one particle at a time.
And they all add-- each of
these particles has forces.
You sum them all up.
You get these forces,
and this allows
you to say that the sum of
all of the external forces
on the system is equal
to the total mass
of the system times
the acceleration
of the center of mass.
So this formula
now can-- it looks
very similar to where we started
with this little derivation
for a particle.
You can now say that
the summation-- this all
leads to the summation
of the integral
from t1 to t2 of all of
these courses over time--
gives you the change in
the total linear momentum
of the system, vg with
respect to o1, 2 rather,
minus vg with respect
to o2, the second one.
So this is exactly the
same kind of formulation.
The change in the linear
momentum of the system
is equal to the integral of the
forces on the system over time,
so the impulse to the system.
So this allows you to do
problems that you might not
have thought about before.
So I think about
something like this.
I've got an old Revolutionary
War earlier period canon.
I'm trying to draw it
So here's my cannon barrel.
And back in those days-- I'll
do a little better job here.
So we got this
cannon sitting here.
And in the barrel,
you've got a bunch
of what's known as-- in the
old days, known as grapeshot.
So sometimes, for
anti personnel stuff,
they would just throw a
whole bunch of metal and junk
into it.
But just imagine a
bunch of iron balls
or lead ball rocks or whatever
you want to put in there.
And you put a whole mess of them
in here, and you have a charge.
You set it off, and it shoots
them out the end of the gun.
I want to know
what's the reaction.
What's the reaction
force on the gun?
When that gun-- when
that charge goes off--
if you go down to the
Constitution, which
is the oldest commissioned
warship in the US Navy
still afloat-- I don't
know if any of you
have seen it down here
in the dock in Chelsea.
It was built around 1799.
But when they shot
one of those guns,
the gun would roll back several
feet and get dragged to a stop
by a bunch of restraining
lines and then dragged back up
for another load.
So the reaction force,
the force pushing back--
these things were usually
sitting on wheels--
could be pretty large.
Let's take an estimate of it.
So this is going to be
a relatively small gun.
The total mass of
the shot here times g
is 10 pounds, so
10 pounds a shot.
A gallon of milk
weighs 8 pounds,
so this isn't a very big load.
And let's say that this barrel
here, from here to here,
the acceleration
length is 7 feet.
So that shot is accelerated
out of the barrel
over a distance of 7 feet.
And it has a muzzle
velocity, an exit velocity,
of 700 feet per second.
Most guns, subsonic,
supersonic, projectiles
when they come out of guns,
have you thought about that?
I'm just asking-- seeing if
you have a feeling for speed.
And how close to the
speed of sound is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the
speed of sound is
about 1,100 feet per second,
340 meters per second.
So this is order of mach
0.6 or something like that.
Something like 0.6,
not 0.060, 0.6.
So about 60% of
the speed of sound.
That's slow actually as guns go.
So the initial velocity-- the
shot's just sitting theree--
is 0.
The final velocity is
700 feet per second.
The average velocity, which
I'm going to need for a second
because I'm just making
some estimates here--
the average velocity,
average of 0 plus 700
is 350 feet per second.
The reason I need this is I
need to estimate the delta t.
How long does it take to get
the shot out of the barrel?
So distance equals
rate times time, right?
So the v average times
delta t equals 7 feet.
At 350 feet per
second, you find out
delta t is about 0.02 seconds.
So it gets out the barrel
pretty quickly, 0.02 seconds,
20 milliseconds.
Now, that powder,
when it goes off,
it's putting a lot of
forces on the shot.
So if the total force on
the shot is 5,000 pounds,
what's the reaction
force on the cannon?
So we're going to
apply a principle here
that we talked about earlier.
Newton had three laws.
This is a group.
This is just massive
balls in there.
The hot exploding gases are
pushing them out the barrel.
What must be the push of the
same gas on the canon that's
containing it?
AUDIENCE: Equal and opposite.
PROFESSOR: Equal and
opposite, Newton's Third Law.
Right.
So the reaction force that we're
looking for is minus the force
that it takes to get the
shot out of the barrel.
So the force on the
balls, on the shot,
minus the reaction force.
And that's Newton's Third Law.
So we're almost there.
We're just applying
now this concept
of impulse and momentum.
So now we can say the integral--
and this is a summation.
You got a bunch
of balls in there.
They all got forces
on them, but we're
treating the group
of balls as a system,
so we can use this
notion of the total mass
times the velocity of the center
of gravity to do this problem.
So this is the force on all of
these little balls integrated
over time.
It's going to be the mass total
of the balls times the change
in the velocity of the center
of gravity, the final velocity
minus the initial velocity.
This is 0.
We know this.
So this mt is the
10 pounds over g.
We know this is 700
feet per second.
We know that all
of this mounts up
to the force external
on the group delta t.
And this is the weight
of the ball, w/g.
And this is 700 feet per second.
That's 10 pounds divided
by gravity, 32.12.
And we need to
divide by delta t.
So the external
force on the balls
is w/g delta t times
700 feet per second.
And if you work out those
numbers, you get 10,870 pounds.
Now, this is an average
force because we--
that delta t is
the length of time
it took, assuming we had some--
we assumed an average velocity
going down the barrel.
So the peak force is
probably higher than this,
and the pressure in the barrel
probably isn't constant.
This actually isn't
a bad estimate.
If you know the muzzle velocity,
which you can figure out
probably from the distance
it goes and things like that,
you can make this estimate.
So 10,000 pounds of reaction
force is quite a lot.
This is a dinky gun.
10 pounds a shot is not much.
This is the force to get
the balls out the barrel.
If it's positive, what's
the reaction force?
Minus 10,870.
And all through this, I've been
doing this in a single vector
direction, so I
would have set up
my coordinate system
like here's o.
This is the x
direction, y direction.
Obviously, in the
positive x direction
is what I've lined up
my positive velocities
and positive forces to be.
So this is a really simple way.
One of the kind of
ways in which you
use this notion of
impulse and momentum
that you can use to
make estimates too.
Any of you ever
fired a shot gun.
Not many.
There's-- yeah.
Any kick?
Right.
So what gauge
shotgun did you fire?
You don't know.
OK.
A 12-gauge shot gun.
12-gauge shot gun, the
cartridge is just about 3/4
of an inch diameter and
probably has a little amount
of powder in there.
It amounts up to
about that much stuff.
But it can give you a
bruise in the shoulder
if you don't hold it right.
So that's what this is about.
So this quick
review, you've done
lots of conservation of
momentum problems in your time.
The homework set this time has
two or three problems on it
that are conservation of
momentum, linear momentum.
But now I want to move on to
talking about angular momentum.
And angular momentum, in a
way in which you probably
haven't done angular
momentum problems before.
So anything about
last thing on this.
So mostly this, I want
you to read the chapter.
I think it's chapter 15.
The first few sections of
it are on linear momentum,
the last few sections
on angular momentum.
Go read them and just
work the problems.
That's where you'll get
most of your refresher
is doing the practice problems.
Angular momentum.
So we'll start with particle.
We're very rapidly going
to get to rigid bodies.
Now many times, you've done
angular momentum problems
before, mostly rotations
about fixed axes.
So here's our inertial
frame, fixed x,y and you have
a particle out here.
And it just has some mass, m.
And it has some total
force on it, the force.
And this says the
particle is located
at B here, so the force
at B, total force at B,
just some vector.
It also is traveling with
some velocity at that instant
in time, so it has momentum.
Momentum is p of this particle
at B with respect to o.
And I'd like to-- the
standard expression
then for the angular momentum
of this particle at B
with respect to o-- we have
a position vector here,
r Bo, which we've used
lots of times by now,
is just the cross product
of the position vector
with the linear momentum.
And that's the definition
of angular momentum.
I'm using a lowercase
h here, so they're
going to do that to
indicate single particles.
And I'll use a capital
H later on when we're
referring to rigid bodies.
So the angular momentum
of this particle,
with respect to this
point, is given by that.
And where you've
used this before,
then, it's the derivative
of hB with respect
to o dt is-- what's that?
Remember, where
does this give you?
The time rate of change of
the angular momentum is the?
AUDIENCE: Torque
PROFESSOR: Torque.
Right.
And it's the torque.
It's a sum of the
torques applied
on that object with respect
to the coordinate system
in which you're computing
the angular momentum.
So that's-- we've used
this formula many times.
And in planar motion
where you only
have one axis of rotation
using the z-axis of rotation,
you usually would write
this as I theta double dot.
In simplest form, if
it's a rigid body,
it has a mass moment
of inertia times
theta double dot is equal to
the sum of the external torque.
So that's where you've
met this before.
But for the moment,
this is just a particle.
Let's stick with a particle.
So the piece that's
new here-- probably new
for you-- is that what if I want
to know the angular momentum
with respect to another point?
So here's a point A. I'd like
to compute hB with respect to A.
Well, that's rB with respect to
A cross PB with respect to o.
And this is really
easy to forget.
The momentum is always
calculated with respect
to your inertial frame.
And that's why I keep
in this with respect to
and telling you what the
frame is is pretty important.
But we're out here at
some arbitrary point,
computing the cross product
of the position vector
from this arbitrary point
to this moving mass.
And we're defining--
it's just a definition
defining the angular momentum
with respect to this point A
as r B/A cross PB
with respect to o.
And what I want to get to is now
is the torque on this system,
around this particle,
B with respect to A
is the time rate of change
of h B/A with respect to t.
But now it's a little
more complicated.
Plus, the velocity
of A with respect
to o-- these are all vectors--
cross PB with respect to o.
Messy term.
I was trying to
think of an example
where you might want to do this.
So imagine that you've got
an arm which can rotate.
It might be on a robot
or something like that.
And it has attached to it
another arm with a mass on it.
And you've got a motor here,
which can make this rotate.
And you're trying to
design-- the motor has
to be able to put out a
certain amount of torque.
So this is o.
This is B. This is
A. And you actually--
I want to know the torque
required in this motor
to drive this thing around.
But the motor is
here, and it only
cares about what it feels,
so the torque at this point
to drive this thing.
But this whole system
is now in motion.
You'd have to use this formula.
So there are
practical times when
you'd like to be able to
calculate something like this.
So there's a--
we're going to show
you a very brief
derivation of this
just so you can get a
feeling for where this comes
from because there's
a couple of outcomes
that are very important to it.
So the sum of the forces
there at-- those forces at B,
give you the time rate
of change of the momentum
at B with respect to o.
This is the momentum
vector of our particle.
And this fB, this is the
total external forces
acting on the particle.
And we know that's m.
It's a single particle
times the velocity of That
certainly could be right.
That's our familiar
formula for F equals ma.
So the time derivative of a
linear momentum gives you this.
And the torque of
B with respect to A
is r B/A cross-- I'm going let
this just be a total vector.
I'll call it fB.
It's a vector.
The torque with
respect to A is just
r B/A cross this
total external force.
r B/A cross time
derivative of P B/o.
Because the forces
give us r if it's
from the time rate of change
of the linear momentum
of that particle.
So I can say it like this.
But now there is just a
little vector identity
for products of vectors that
I'm going to take advantage.
And I'll call this Q.
So Q is of the form--
and I'm going to say this
is a quantity of vector A,
and this is a quantity
of vector-- time
derivative of a vector
B. It's A cross dB dt.
So there's a little
identity that you can use.
It says A cross dB dt.
You can alternatively write
that as the time derivative
of A cross B minus time
derivative of A cross B.
We're going to take
advantage of this
and just re-construct this
formula using this expression.
So that says torque
of B with respect to A
is the time derivative
of r B/A cross P
B/o minus the derivative
of r B/A cross P B/o.
So we've just made this
substitution down here in terms
of r B/A and P B/o all vectors.
We know that r B/A, from all
the previous work we've done,
is just r B/o minus r
A/o so the derivative
of r B/A with respect to
time is v B/o minus v A/o
We're almost there.
I'm going to need another board.
This quantity here,
this is just h B/A.
This is the angular momentum of
the particle with respect to A.
It's just r cross
B, if you recall.
So then we can rewrite this
expression for the torque
as the time derivative
of h of B with respect
to A. That's because of
what I pointed out there.
Now, this is minus v B/o
minus v A/o cross P B/o.
So P of B with
respect to o is just
m velocity of B
with respect to o.
So v B/o cross P
B/o gives you what?
Nothing.
Gives you 0 because they are
in parallel of the angle,
and they're in the
same direction.
So you only get a nonzero piece
out of this minus times minus
gives you a plus, and you
end up with-- and that's
what we set out to find.
I said this is where
I was trying to get,
and now we're there.
Now importantly,
there's a couple
of special cases of this.
This can be a nuisance
term to have to deal with.
Lots of times you'd like
to be able to get rid of it
and just be able to go back
to that old reliable formula,
torque is time rate of
change of angular momentum.
So there are two obvious--
maybe obvious conditions
in which this will go away.
What's the most obvious one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
change to 0.
PROFESSOR: Something,
what you say was 0?
AUDIENCE: One of the terms
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah.
This term presumably not.
This guy, if this
is 0, it's just back
to our old familiar formula.
That's one case, so case one.
But now-- actually, this is
a really important result
because A can be anywhere
as long as it's not moving.
So this allows you
to do things, talk
about rotations
about fixed axes that
aren't at the center of mass.
So if you have a fixed axis
of rotation and something
going around it, that's
what this allows you to do.
That's one case.
So this is--
We'll soon get to rigid bodies.
Rigid bodies obey exactly
the same formulas.
And you can have
a rigid body, now,
that is not rotating
about its center,
but rotating maybe
about its end like this.
That formula applies
if the velocity
of that axis about which it's
rotating, about which you're
computing, is not
moving, then you can just
use-- you don't have to
deal with that messy term.
So this is one case in
which this term goes away.
The other case is if
this velocity is parallel
to the direction
of the momentum.
And there's a really useful
time that that happens.
So also this formula is true.
Case two is when
v A/o is parallel
to P B/o, the direction.
You're going in
the same direction.
Now that happens when
A-- it's guaranteed
to be true if A is
at the center of mass
because the momentum is defined
as the mass of the object
times the velocity of its center
of mass, even for rigid bodies.
So this is true when A
is-- and I'll call it
G-- at the center of mass.
So this gives us another
really important generalization
that we'll use-- that we make
great use of in dynamics.
And that says that the
torque, with respect
to the center of mass,
is time rate of change
of h with respect
to G. Now, I'm not
going to go-- I did the proof--
went through this little proof
just for a particle.
But by summing a
bunch of particles
and going through all
the summations, as we
did, to prove the
center of mass formula,
you can show-- this allows
you to very quickly show
that this formulation is
also true for rigid bodies.
So the way you say it
for rigid bodies is
that the sum of the
torques, with respect
to some point for a rigid body,
is capital H dot with respect
to A plus the velocity of A
with respect to o cross P.
And now I'm going to say G,
its center of mass, center
of gravity, with respect to o.
So the same statement
for a rigid body
is that the torque with
respect to some point A, which
can be moving now--
even accelerating--
is the time rate of
change of the angular
momentum with respect to A
of that rigid body plus v A/o
cross P B/o.
And again, when would this
messy second term go to 0?
When the velocity of A is 0,
fixed axis rotation, or when
this is parallel to that, which
is true for the center of mass
always.
So the same two special
cases apply for rigid bodies
when velocity of A with
respect to 0 equals 0
or when the velocity of A with
respect to o is parallel the P.
And the most important case
of that is always true.
It's always the case.
And in these you can say this.
Then, the torque,
with respect to A,
is dH, with respect to A dt.
No second terms.
And it's those kinds
of-- you've applied,
generally in your physics like
in 801, you've used formulas
like this a lot.
Done problems
either with respect
to the center of mass so objects
were doing things like that.
You'll do the torque
formulas with respect
to the center of mass.
Or when you have things that
are pinned to points and rotate
about fixed axes, then
use the other formulation
where it is with respect
to a non-moving point.
So this is fixed axis rotation.
So that's the dry
derivation part of it.
I'm going to see if I
can find an example here.
This is quite a
bit like a number
of the homework problems.
So I've got a carnival ride.
I got a bar.
And it's got a seat out here.
You're riding in it.
So you're taking this ride.
It's rotating.
This is some fixed axis here.
You have a fixed coordinate
system, your o x, y, z.
And then you'd probably have
some rotating coordinate system
with the point A fixed here
at the axis of rotation.
And this is going-- what's
unusual about this ride,
not only can it go
around and round,
but the arm can go in and out.
So it might take a
path inwards, like you
pull the arm in as
you're going around.
What are the forces that
you feel in the ride?
So this is my point B out here.
It's where the person's at.
You have some mass, m.
And let's let, for now,
the first case-- theta
dot, let that be constant, the
constant angular rate here.
Here's theta and r dot.
Now, you already know quite
a bit about things like this.
If your riding in that
bucket, what forces
do you think you would feel?
Or I should say
it more carefully.
There will be accelerations
that you feel in that bucket.
You'll feel like forces on you.
But what are the
accelerations that you
will feel-- you expect to
be if you're riding in it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I hear one here.
AUDIENCE: Centripetal
acceleration.
PROFESSOR: So there will be
centripetal acceleration,
right.
Everybody agree with that?
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Coriolis acceleration.
PROFESSOR: There's going
to be some Coriolis
because r dot is not 0.
It's changing in
position, but when
the length of the
arm of something
rotating at constant speed
changes, what momentum changes?
AUDIENCE: Angular.
PROFESSOR: Angular, for sure.
How about linear momentum?
Yeah, it's changing too because
r cross P is angular momentum.
So both linear and
angular momentum
are changing as this radius
gets longer or shorter.
And if that angular
momentum changes,
it takes torque to drive it.
And so we ought to be able to
use the formulas that we've
just derived to
calculate something
about the torques required
to make this happen
and the forces on the rider.
So we'll treat this
one as a particle.
So H, the angular momentum
of the rider out here,
at B with respect to o, is
going to be r B/o cross P.
And in this problem, I'll
use polar coordinates.
Pretty easy.
This is a planar motion problem.
It's confined to the x,y
plane and rotation z,
so polar coordinates
are pretty convenient.
So this should look like
radius r r hat cross--
and the linear
momentum of this is
the mass-- times r dot r hat.
That's the extension
rate, but it also
has velocity in this theta
hat direction, r theta hat.
So this is P was respected
o, m, v. And this
is the radius-- this is
the r crossed into it.
Now r hat cross r
hat gives you 0,
so you only get a
single term out of this.
And you get an r cross-- r hat
cross, theta hat, positive k.
So this looks like plus m r
squared, theta dot, k hat.
That's my H B/o.
Now, I would-- that's my first
piece that I wanted to get.
That's the a part.
That's find the
angular momentum.
So this is a.
b, I want to know the torque.
Well, which formula can we use?
Are we allowed to use--
do we have to account
for that second term?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Velocity.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
The velocity of the
point about which we're
computing, the angular momentum,
and therefore, the torques,
is not moving.
So you only have to deal
with the first term.
So the torque required to
move that particle at B
with respect to o is just
a time rate of change
d by dt of h B
with respect to o.
And that's d by dt of m r
squared theta dot k hat.
So what are the constants
in this expression
so we don't have to worry
about their derivatives?
Does k hat change length?
No.
Change direction?
Theta dot, does it
change in this problem?
No, we fixed it.
We arbitrarily started
off saying that we'll just
let theta dot be constant.
r, though, is changing.
So the time derivative
of this particular one,
we only have to deal with the r.
Actually, I'll forget
that for a second
because I want to
get both terms,
and then we'll let it be 0.
So this time derivative
then, when you work it
out-- the derivative
of the r term
gives you 2mr r dot
theta dot k hat.
And I'll just go ahead
and forget for a minute
that I said that's constant.
Let's get the other term
that might be there.
That term gives us m r squared
theta double dot k hat.
This term comes from what
we'll find is the Coriolis one.
And this is from what we call
the Eulerian acceleration.
The torque-- let me get
this up a little higher.
We should be able to
write as some r cross f.
And so the r cross
f terms, this will
be from the Coriolis force.
And this would be from
that Eulerian force.
So this will look
like r r hat cross--
I'm just factoring this back
out into its cross products--
r r hat cross 2m
r dot theta dot,
in the theta hat direction,
plus r theta double dot,
in the theta hat direction.
So there's two terms in
this torque expression.
They come from r
cross, two force terms.
The first force term is what we
know to be the Coriolis force.
And the second force term--
I am missing an m here.
r m theta double dot
theta hat, that's
the force that it takes to--
if the thing were accelerating,
just to accelerate that ball,
theta double dot takes a force.
You do these cross products.
r cross theta hat give you k.
R cross theta hat give you k.
It all comes out in
the right directions.
And now to do the
problem we had,
we said, oh yeah,
let this one be 0.
So we'll let this term go to 0.
We're left with a single term.
And if we plugged
in some numbers--
let's just see how
this works out.
And this we know is just
r cross the Coriolis.
Well, let's let m-- if
you let m be 100 kilograms
and r be 5 meters
and r dot, 0.4 meters
per second-- they're
all perfectly reasonable
dimensions.
And theta dot equals
3 radians per second.
So 2 pi radians per second means
it goes around once a second.
So this is a little less
than half a rev per second.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is this still
[INAUDIBLE] though,
or does it--
PROFESSOR: Probably.
Yeah.
Good catch!
Got to have on r in it because
that r comes from here, right?
So I had the Coriolis
force written down,
but not the r you have
to multiply it by.
So now if you plug in
all of these numbers,
let's see if it's a
ride you could survive.
I actually computed the
Coriolis force first.
I think it's just interesting
to get a physical feeling
for how-- whether or not
you can feel these forces.
So the Coriolis force
is just everything
but the r, 2m r dot theta dot.
So if you calculate that,
you get 240 newtons.
And r times that, the torque.
5 times that, about
1,200 Newton meters.
And the acceleration, how
do we get acceleration?
Well, f cor, Coriolis
force, is some mass
times an acceleration.
So we can solve, from
that 240 newtons,
the acceleration of the system.
Our acceleration of B with
respect to o, 240 newtons
divided by 100 kilograms, 2.4
meters per second squared.
And what's that in g's.
AUDIENCE: About 1/4.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, about
a quarter of a g.
And again, would you feel that?
So now you riding in the bucket.
Let's say it's just
spinning around.
The arm is not going
in and out at all.
So you're riding in it.
What force would you feel?
Would you feel any forces
pushing you into your seat?
Constant speed, r dot's 0.
Somebody out there,
would you feel any force
if you're going around and
around in this thing sitting
in a seat?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What's it come from?
AUDIENCE: Centripetal
acceleration.
PROFESSOR: Centripetal
And that is in what direction?
AUDIENCE: It's inward.
PROFESSOR:
Accelerations is inward.
What would you actually feel?
You'd feel-- if this
seat could swing out
so your facing in, you'd feel
like you're being thrown out
in your seat, right?
Because you have to
have a force on you
to make that
acceleration happen.
Acceleration is inward.
The force had better
be pushing you inward.
So it's pushing on your back if
you're look in, going around.
So that's the-- I've
forgotten the term for it.
But put the astronauts
in a centrifuge,
spin around to see if
they can take high g's.
That's the inward
high g acceleration
due to the centripetal
acceleration,
makes you go in a circle.
But now not only are you going
to feel that, but now you start
changing the length of the arm.
And if you change r dot
and make it positive
so the arm is getting
longer, and we made
this 0.4 meters per second.
So it's moving out
about like that.
It's not real fast.
But it's going to create a
quarter of a g acceleration
on you.
And if r dot's positive, which
direction is that acceleration?
I was careful.
We walked all the
way through this.
The acceleration is positive,
but in what direction?
It's the Coriolis.
AUDIENCE: Theta hat.
PROFESSOR: Theta hat,
positive theta hat,
so it's in the direction
of increasing theta.
So this one is
perpendicular to the arm.
And this is the--
one of my ping pong
balls in here, the force that
actually causes it to speed up
is partly Coriolis and
partly or Eulerian.
If I can make this go at
constant speed, the force that
drives that-- the force
that actually speeds that up
as they're going out is the
Coriolis force, the normal one.
So if you were on
this ride, you'd
be feel about a quarter of a
g perpendicular to the arm.
You'd be filling
another force inward
that's the
centripetal-- caused by
the centripetal acceleration.
So you'd be feeling
both of them.
How big is the
centripetal acceleration?
Like r omega squared, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: r is 5.
Omega is 3.
3 Squared is 9, times 5-- 9
times 5, 45, divided by 10,
4 and 1/2 g's.
You wouldn't notice
the Coriolis very much.
It would be a tough ride
on that side of things.
Now, we've done that-- you've
seen a simple application,
pretty straightforward
application,
of using time derivative
of angular momentum
to calculate torques.
So on homework, again,
there's a couple problems
very similar to the one I
just did, things going around,
circus rides, that
kind of stuff.
So have a good weekend.
See you on Tuesday.